zach from the try guys has come out and
said that he has an autoimmune condition
i'm about to watch the video and react
to it let's get to it
i have had really bad back issues
basically my entire life perfect i'm an
osteopathic physician this is gonna go
really well i was going to the
chiropractor when i was 10. i had to
have like an ergonomic backpack in
middle school i mean everyone should
have an ergonomic backpack in school in
fact my theory is that a lot of the
scoliosis that kids are developing these
days come from uneven backpacks wearing
them on one shoulder or even those desks
where you can only lean on one side i
ache i get stiff it kind of started uh
before i went to buzzfeed a lot of my
time would be spent at a computer and i
noticed i would just
when i sneezed i could feel the pain
shoot from my back through the front
through my chest cage the way that he's
describing his pain right away tells me
that there's some kind of inflammation
happening at the rib joints because
remember the ribs attach to the front of
your chest the sternum at least the
upper ribs here and then also to your
spine in the back the thoracic spine i
have a bit of a hypochondria
and so whenever something's wrong with
me i'm like cancer it's cancer cancer so
i told my doctor about this pain he says
that's not a thing you're good if you're
a doctor and a patient's coming in with
a high level of anxiety about a
condition and you know they're
susceptible to health related anxiety
you have to right away be ultra
transparent and honest about what you're
doing and why you're doing it not just
give statements like you're good and
move on i decided it was time to go to
the chiropractor we took an x-ray turns
out i have scoliosis so scoliosis
doesn't always require treatment we
blame a lot of problems on patient
scoliosis when it's actually not the
main cause it's very easy in a patient
who's having back pain caused by
something completely different to get an
x-ray and blame it all on the scoliosis
in fact it's the lazy thing to do a
small degree of scoliosis shouldn't be
causing significant discomfort in fact
most cases of scoliosis that we see are
extremely mild and are asymptomatic now
for anyone who has scoliosis they will
be the first people to tell you that my
scoliosis is minor it's not because you
would get surgery for i tried a lot of
things to help this i changed my diet i
don't know what the diet would help with
scoliosis with unless he had a bone
mineral deficiency there the main thing
that you do for mild scoliosis like this
is not even bracing not surgery
obviously physical therapy doing some
exercise some lifestyle modifications
make sure you're not wearing a book pad
got only on one side the pain built to a
point where i couldn't sleep i woke up
at like 4 45 in pain this was every
night for for months
laying down
hurt
uh being in my bed
hurt
i mean living
hurt i'm talking about i would wake up
in the middle of the night five times
all during this i am i'm working a
full-time job but when you're not
sleeping it it eats away at you mentally
it absolutely does because you don't
recover well you're constantly in a
hyper sympathetic state where it's like
you're basically being chased by a lion
you're never relaxing you're never
digesting you're never repairing and
healing and as a doctor you have to ask
these things because when we ask how
much disability a certain injury is
causing you it's not about whether or
not you can walk or run or lift or not
it's also about can you rest adequately
can you sleep well can you sit well can
you perform the duties at your job well
i start screaming i think and i feel bad
for the doctor but i was like hey this
can't continue i'm losing my mind i got
referred to a rheumatologist and within
minutes the rheumatologist is like oh
yeah i think i know what's wrong with
you and i'm like what i'm interested
what conversation they had in the
medical office that led him to go to see
a rheumatologist who's essentially an
autoimmune joint disease expert why they
went that route versus a spinal surgeon
for example it could have been that he
wasn't interested in spine surgery but
there has to have been tip offs to some
sort of autoimmune process i had to go
in for an mri which was scary because at
that point i didn't know what was wrong
with me he just referred me to an mri
and i'm like okay oh god what is this an
mri is magnetic resonance imaging where
you have giant magnets essentially spin
around you to give us really good
quality images it's really loud it's
very claustrophobic some of my patients
actually need benzodiazepine medications
which are anti-anxiety medications to
even be able to get an mri they do a
great job at showing soft tissue like an
x-ray for example will show bone quite
well or joints well the mri would show
us cartilage tendons ligaments organs it
turns out i have ankylosing spondylitis
ankylosing spondylitis is basically an
inflammatory autoimmune condition where
usually starts in the sacroiliac joint
which is the joint between your hips and
one of the lower portions of your spine
your sacrum it can get so bad that it
starts spreading to other vertebral
joints moving up your back where you
develop stiffness and in the worst
conditions actually the joints fuse and
you become very stiff it becomes very
painful think about inflammation in the
joint this was about four months ago i
am happy to report that since that time
i've been on medication and i have felt
better than i have felt since like
childhood i take a drug called humera so
no matter where i am no matter what i'm
doing i have to stop what i'm doing and
give myself a little shot
you ready to get poked
we hold on to zack's medicine i have to
take this medication twice a month at
the same time so uh it's 8 40 am and i
got to take this shot this is a
medication that's used as a
disease-modifying anti-rheumatic drug
and these dmards work through different
processes but the medication he takes
targets tumor necrosis factor and it
actually allows the decrease of
inflammation where he has an unnecessary
increase and so what's great is that you
never actually see the needle
oh right that's nice see this window
right here
some yellow liquid is going to pop out
of it
but that's it now i'm done so i started
my medication and for a few months
my life was incredible i was able to
sleep throughout the night without
waking up in pain i wasn't stiff
throughout the day it's important to
remember as he's talking about his
experience with this medication that is
not a cure for his condition it's a
disease modifying drug so it changes the
course the development making the
progression slower that's the most
important takeaway during this time i
was instructed to keep up with physical
activity
but as the months passed i
got a little wax i was back to where i
was the truth is i
started ignoring my disease the second i
could the moment that my medicine
started working i
stopped paying attention to it so it was
time to go back to the doctor finally
ready to accept and confront my symptoms
and ready to attack this sickness head
on and
he said i was fine
my inflammatory markers were still low
if a patient is coming in and saying
they're suffering again with their
illness that they feel like it's making
a return they're going back to where
they were and i come in and i say no
your inflammatory cells are good
that's not adequate medical care we
never treat lab values we don't treat
inflammatory cells if a patient's coming
in and telling me they have back pain if
a patient's telling me that they have
terrible crippling anxiety and
depressive symptoms i don't say oh your
labs look good so deuces i decided to
make my health a full-time job
physical therapy twice a week yoga and
stretching first thing when i wake up
and last thing before i go to bed long
box with bowie every single day instead
of letting someone else walk him for me
and exercise especially on the days that
i don't want to accepting that sometimes
being late to work in the morning is a
necessary component to my health the
movement component and the healing that
comes from moving is amazing because
whether it's a medication a massage
physical therapy all of that is in place
so your body heals itself and a body
that's not in motion will continue
staying not in motion and continue being
in pain and after all that
i feel okay
i still have a baseline of pain
most days i don't know that i'm never
gonna fully be a hundred percent again
but i am done ignoring my pain that's
really powerful because acceptance is a
big part of chronic pain a lot of times
we promise patients that we can fully
get rid of their pain go from 100 to
zero and a lot of times that's not
feasible most notably so when it comes
to opioid treatments patients that are
promised zero pain are giving opioids
their pain goes to zero but then we
can't continue those in many cases long
term unless that there's an end point
there's a goal for something check out
my video of michael reeves and his
bladder exploding what click it it's the
most fascinating story he's actually in
the video with me click here to check
that out and as always stay happy and
healthy